so Andrew Tate basically uh said the
following so Andrew Tate said to Ben
Shapiro Mr tough guide just for Ben
Shapiro do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop all of
us it's extremely beneficial to do this
course definitely recommend this course
to access the free lifechanging training
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends as you guys know there is an
outright genocide happening in Palestine
with Subhan Allah what's been going on
and at the same time we condemn the
kingom of innocent people whoever they
are yes Jewish people whoever they are
for that matter yes because in Islam is
very categorically clear that you are
not allowed to Target innocent people je
Muslim whatever for that matter yeah but
but also it should be born in mind that
some people are trying to frame it like
it's a religious thing exactly I mean
even the UK prime minister went to a
synagogue when it's not a religious
thing it's a geopolitical thing exactly
it's an issue to do with land exactly
and there's no scripture in the Quran or
Hadith or anywhere that in the Bible the
Old Testament it says that go and kill
men innocent children babies we don't
have that in our religion and we are not
not we are not aware we're not familiar
with this kind of idea of going and
storting men women and children which
the Christian Judo Christian uh uh uh
things that are mentioned in the uh uh
the Bible and Testament so there is an
online War also happening between Ben
Shapiro this individual who is actually
indirect or very directly condoning the
genocide somebody whose parents maybe
his grandparents went through the
Holocaust something that was so tragic
that killed millions of innocent Jewish
people which we condemn someone who's
gone through that not himself but
witness his grandparents to come and
inflict the same thing not maybe himself
but to Advocate it bro it's as good
being you complicit in it I'm so sorry
so the war between these two and Andrew
Tate Brothers here is what has been said
so Andrew Tate basically said the
following so Andrew Tate said to Ben
Shapiro Mr tough guy let me assure you
as someone who has done his own fighting
as opposed to excitedly encouraging
others to do it for him while sitting at
at home on a comfy chair and this is
rightly so so this weasel this scum Ben
Shapiro says let me assure you as
someone who has not pimped woman and
bragged about it the morality requir
that those who rape women and kidnap
children must be eradicated not
negotiated with so Tristan Tate came
along and he said a Jewish man speaking
of er eradication of a race of people
2023 is a scary time to be alive I
wonder how many of the women and kids
who are soon to be obl obliterated
kidnapped or raped my guess is zero this
is this is nihilistic and evil so for
him to come and make it seem as if
Andrew Tate has been outright proven
that he has done these crimes yes
there's nothing for that matter but if
we was to put it into a liberal
workframe yeah consequentially yes if we
was to look at it which is which is
worse we believe both are worse yes if
you're taking these women and grooming
them for that matter Etc argument sake
we believe that this didn't happen until
it's proven in otherwise consequentially
which is wrong bro killing bombing
innocent children stealing their lands
and and currently
currently 14 140 kids have been
massacred yes or somebody who it is not
even proven that him going and grooming
woman yes which one consequentially is
wrong I think it's clear for any person
with a single brain cell in their head
with an IQ of more than one yes that
person would say killing somebody is
worse because like the Quran says it's
as if you're wiping out an entire
generation and funnny enough Ben Shapiro
is that very individual who's advocating
this so you are here pointing fingers at
Andrew Tate yes and his brother who's a
Christian yes and by the way there's
many Christians in palestin who are
being oppressed by the way they're being
spat at frankly spat at bro spat at and
then when they complain they get told
well this is our custom frankly exactly
so the thing is here and the only one
that should be spat at is you because
you are an advocate to that movement
have you condemned are you going to spit
at him as well I might do when the video
finishes I might do that yeah okay as
long as you going to do the animation
edits yeah so here if you think about it
brothers and sisters you are more of a
vile creature you are more of a vile
human being for advocating the absolute
Massacre genocide to the Palestinian
people and you have not condemned once
the killing of innocent people which you
deem to be damage and you want to
question andate with these allegations
that are made towards him the it's you
it's the the you have shot yourself on
the foot so we are here alhamdulillah on
the side again of Andrew T why because
even his brother Tristan Tate they can
see that the innoc innocent Palestinian
kids children have been massacred for
the past 75 Years bro yeah this guy
clearly has selective memory yeah I mean
for the last decades that we've been
alive frankly we've been seeing you know
every other year every every year
frankly there's some big event happening
whether yeah whether they storming our
holy sites you know going in and
throwing women about and you know stuff
that I can't even mention for even the
censor the people at the censor Boards
of of YouTube are you know linked to the
Israeli defense as well I mean there's
only so much that can be said however if
a person that is nuanced and balanced on
social media they will see on a regular
basis Palestinians constantly being
assaulted constantly being maimed and he
you have Tristan
who is a Christian who is you know he's
not a Muslim but even he can see you
know what this is wrong and the
mentality of this guy because look you
can you can be you know furious at
innocence being killed that's fine but
you should also be balanced and call a
spade a spade if it's happening to your
people or the other or or to another
people you should still be balanced and
a human life is a human life unless you
don't deem them to be human and that's
the thing and that's why you've got the
defense secretary calling them uh
Palestinians Gaza Palestinians or Human
animals what is a human animal it's just
sophistry for animal you're dehumanizing
them which was done in Iraq before
wiping out a million people and that's
let's go before that it was done by
Hitler of course it was done by King Leo
Paul II also in Congo yeah and it was
done by Churchill to the bangladeshis as
well there there's loads of these but
unfortunately there are some things that
get promoted more than others but like
we've said and we're going to stay
consistent a death is tragic and should
be mourned regardless of what the color
of the skin or religion it is from The
River To The Sea Palestine will be free
just for Ben
Shapiro oh it landed goodbye